con pausa este vídeo y trata de ver si
puedes restar esta expresión magenta de
esta expresión amarilla por tu propia
cuenta aunque después vamos a hacerlo
todos juntos muy bien ahora lo primero
que debe brincar te a la vista es que en
realidad estas dos expresiones no tienen
el mismo denominador pero nos gustaría
que así fuera verdad así que tenemos que
reescribir estos estos dos comandos para
que para que tengan un denominador común
y uno que funcionaría sería digamos uno
que fuera divisible por cada uno que
fuera divisible entre cada uno de estos
denominadores verdad es decir que tenga
todos los factores de ambos muy bien
entonces vamos a tratar de reescribir
esto voy a ponerlo de esta forma vamos a
poner una línea un poquito más grande
verdad entonces el el denominador común
que estamos buscando al menos debe tener
estos dos factores z mas 8
9 z menos 5 pero también debe tener los
factores de este otro denominador y como
podemos ver este factor ya está incluido
en lo que hemos escrito así que lo único
que tenemos que agregar es el factor z
más 6 entonces aquí nos falta z más 6
muy bien esto es sería nuestro
denominador que estamos buscando verdad
entonces si nos damos cuenta hemos
dividido en tres etapas 6 así que para
que no se altere esta expresión
necesitamos multiplicar también en el
numerador por z más 6 así que teníamos
menos zeta cúbica y hay que multiplicar
por z más 6 muy bien y ahora vamos a
hacer este mismo procedimiento pero con
la otra expresión
vamos a poner una línea más grande
verdad y aquí tendríamos a z más 67 6
por 9 z menos 5 verdad esos son estos
dos factores y el único que nos falta es
poner z +8 verdad
z + 8 que este no estaba en la expresión
original verdad así que si hemos
dividido en 13 está más 8 aquí en el
numerador también hay que poner z más 8
y esto por supuesto tiene que
multiplicar a lo que ya teníamos que es
3 muy bien entonces ya tenemos estas dos
expresiones estas dos son equivalentes a
las que teníamos anteriormente pero la
ventaja es que ahora estas dos tienen un
denominador común verdad entonces vamos
a ahora a hacer la resta voy a hacer
esta línea más o menos grande ya con un
color neutro y pondré los de el
denominador común más bien nada más es
una verdad zeta más 8 x 9 z menos 5 x
zeta + 6 muy bien y ahora si lo único
que nos falta es restar estas dos
expresiones una vez que ya los hayamos
desarrollado entonces por ejemplo esta
primera expresión
esta primera expresión sería menos zeta
cúbica por zeta sería
z a la cuarta y luego menos z cúbica por
seis verdad sería menos seis z cúbica y
ahora tendríamos que restar este
numerador verdad o lo que es lo mismo
podríamos sumar este numerador pero x
menos 1 verdad entonces sería menos 3
por zetas serían menos 3 z y menos 3 por
8 sería menos 24 muy bien entonces esta
es digamos ya la expresión simplificada
de lo que teníamos anteriormente verdad
de esta resta de dos expresiones
racionales ya lo tenemos sólo tuvimos
que hallar un denominador común verdad y
con ello simplemente restamos los
numeradores ya que habíamos obtenido
este denominador común y de hecho lo
expresamos como una suma al poner el
signo menos en este 3 digamos en el 3
verdad luego simplificamos el numerador
aunque en este caso no había necesidad
de simplificar ya que en todos los
términos todos esto
2 tenían digamos potencias distintas de
nuestra variable zeta verdad entonces
esto ya no lo podemos simplificar así
que hemos terminado